he went on Johnny Carson in 1982 I
believe it was your first spot and
people don't understand now because
there's so much TV and okay this
comedian went on this show where that
show and it doesn't mean what it meant
when Carson was the only show in the
world
very few Comics get to go on it's almost
impossible and if you do get on it's a
big deal and you went on
and if I'm remembering it correctly
Johnny was so impressed you were so
different and so smart that they invited
you back very quickly is that true yes I
went on Friday and then the next
Thursday which hadn't I mean that didn't
happen it was insane when they called me
on Wednesday Jim McCauley he started
talking about the show and I thought he
was review referring to the one that
happened I didn't understand what he
meant he said no no we want you to go on
tomorrow did you have another set I I
had I had another set but I I had like a
total of
15 minutes of
stuff that could go on there and I
remember saying it to him but if I go on
there tomorrow that's three years half
this more than half the stuff is gone
and he simply said well you're gonna
have to write new stuff anyway
and he's to go on twice in one week is
so amazing it had it was unprecedented
at the time and that was a time when if
you went on that show you were famous
overnight
I mean people knew people recognized you
the next day because that was all
anybody was doing at 11 30 at night was
watching Johnny Carson yeah because it
was three channels and yeah the cable
was just starting it was like going
through
Alice in Wonderland going through the
door yeah there you know and Peter or
Sally you know this you saw me and the
Jing Ho Chinese restaurant in Cambridge
if he was the producer of The Tonight
Show and then two weeks later I was on
there I've I had we were talking outside
in the driveway do you remember when we
were in the driveway yeah it was about
15 minutes ago
I'm still capable of remembering things
but yes there wasn't a judgment on you
it was just simply uh I'm very accurate
I don't even know what I was saying uh
we were talking about you're at the Ding
Ho oh he flukes flukes different
accidents accidents little things that
happen to change the course of your life
contribute contribute you know someone
wrote an article about that Chinese
restaurant and went in the LA Times I
don't know why then he saw it and eight
months later he was going in the summer
to go to Massachusetts in New York
because his kids were going to go to
college so they went on a College summer
trip and they remembered the article so
he calls up and you know it's just a lot
flukes yeah I'm very fortunate so you do
that and
you've it's clear that
impressionism and or abstract I'll use
the word abstract abstraction is really
important to you and there must have
been a time in your life when you were a
kid or something where you were you saw
abstract art or you read abstract
writing and it rang a giant Bell in your
head it wasn't the writing it was
Salvador Dali
come by surrealism when I had a art
class 11th grade in Burlington Mass we
went into Boston to one of the main
museums and that's where I first saw
surrealism I never even heard of
surrealism and two of the paintings I
remember there was a painting of a of a
closed pin in the in the middle of the
field and it was the size of a silo but
it didn't look cartoonish it didn't look
ridiculous it was like oh my God and
then there was another painting of a
road coming down like this and then when
it went down like that it turned into a
waterfall and I mean I was 16 I'm
telling you these paintings I was jolted
by the combining of these two realities
and a lot of the writing we were just
talking about the Mosaic thing is like
oh this thing you know this is not a
clothespin you know that jolted me more
than what I read
that was uh
influencing but your head is like a soup
everyone's head is a soup don't you
think it's the ingredients you know
Church fun it gets surrealism
Monty Python The Comedians All Over The
Tonight Show and you know listening to
albums and it all goes into Woody Allen
to me he's still the best he's the top
guy his his writing and all that goes
into your head
I was a big Bruins fan during the Bob
your day you had to be by the way
because I'm I was I was growing up I was
in grade school then I was in second
third grade and all anybody talked about
back then was Bobby Orr
I love you and and Phil Esposito and you
know all and everybody because you know
Bobby Orr was the biggest thing in the
world and in Boston we just couldn't
believe that we had this phenomenal
phenomenal player who was changing the
game yeah it was incredible that time
was incredible and I would listen to the
games in my bed and I had a radio in the
bed and one night I was filmed with the
dial and I stumbled on this show where a
guy played two comedy albums every
Sunday night so I started tuning in
she played cut from one cut to the other
and I'm laying in bed in the dark and
I'm listening for like two years I'm
doing this and it was I didn't know it
but I was like going to
uh School comedy school because I'd be
thinking oh I like that guy I don't like
that but anyway it goes back to the soup
don't you think oh your head is like
made up of all these different random
and sometimes on purpose ingredients
yeah I I think that's that works I don't
you know I prefer a stew a stew yeah
it's a little heartier mine is I think
yours is a very light broth but mine
you're critic you're criticizing me
during my analogy yeah
I want to win I want to win
a win it's a light you at Lowe's and I'm
not putting down a light bra I'm not
putting down a light broth I never
thought I heard you say that it's a
concert it's a consummate no your brain
is a consummate and you taste it and
you're like this is great I've been a
little sick and this is really helping
now I'm like if you've been out in the
woods felling trees you don't want the
Steven Wright consummate you're up
between meal
palette cleanser which and then again no
put down no put down but I'm in a big
crock pot yes
huge chunks of really good sirloin and
potato and there's just some Guinness in
there that really thickens the the kids
you keep going nine more minutes on that
yeah
[Laughter]
why don't you go get a sandwich
there's some yam
um oh my God there's a fit there's all
kinds of thickeners in the broth you
know God it's thick it's a really thick
broth you put the wooden spoon in there
and it stands up on its own if you put a
spoon in mine oh if you put it in yours
it just immediately flips over and falls
on the ground
good
[Laughter]
but no I agree with you I agree with you
but I agree with you there's all this
as long as we've established that mine's
the better yes food
um richer more life-sustaining